it's all this story about the Oregon
football players who were hospitalized
after workouts now they this is January
here that we're talking about I didn't
know if this is where the coach gives
the players sort of a sheet that says
this is what needs to be done without it
being an official n-c-double-a work out
there but you got a new coach in town
Willie Taggart and all of a sudden you
get some organ players who are
hospitalized Andrew greif from The
Oregonian is covering this story and
Andrew joins us this morning Andrew
first of all good morning and second
vault summarize this story bring the
nation up to speed on what's going on
here yeah thanks Dan 70 on this you know
what this story in summary is that last
week was the first week that players got
back on campus for the winter academic
quarter at Oregon you know they had
about a month off from football because
for the first time 2004 Oregon didn't
have a bowl to prepare for and so guys
were basically left to do you know
prescribed workouts but they had to you
know the honor system to get it done
while they were home and when I came
back you know they were put into a
series of really difficult workouts and
they have a new football strength coach
who followed Willie Taggart from South
Florida and you know all during the week
players were tweeting about how they
were they had a new kind of soreness and
now they was really put them through the
paces and at the end of the week three
players they were tested and they felt
they had kind of extreme soreness I felt
it in their arms and they were tested
they found to have these elevated levels
what's called ck that's an indicator for
this syndrome that has the extreme
soreness it rhabdomyolysis and so three
players since the weekend have been in a
hospital here in Eugene area now with
this team supervised or was it as I
mentioned you know offseason where
they'll give you a list of things you
need to do working out but there's no
coaches there now this was from I've
enjoyed supervised okay surprise but you
know how surprising is this with what
we've seen so far that Willie tag
comes in is this his doing or was this
sort of the remnants of you know the
previous regime that these guys weren't
in shape well I think there's a case you
made that there's some of that there
there were something about that make
nothing in shape you know there's a
month off a month off will kill you no
matter who you are what kind of shape
here and that's really tough if you're
not taking it seriously the syndrome is
largely spiked when you come in and you
start intensive workouts and it's a
change because you haven't been doing
such intense workouts for a long time
that contrasts that rapid to go from
static to really dynamic workouts with a
hard workout that's something that's
kind of seen as a baseline cause for the
syndrome you know this actually last
week i wrote a big story about the
review and kind of how the oregon season
unraveled and one of the core complaints
players and coaches had told me was that
during 2016 players weren't working out
hard enough in the weight room but they
were you know one player said they were
cutting corners so i think that's part
of the context in the back story of i
don't know if that went into any of the
new strength plans for hey let's get
these guys you know let's work i'm out
hard kind of let him know or about i
don't know if that was the intent but i
know that's kind of the backstory
leading into this series of hard
workouts as coach tagger talked about
this we talked last night you know he
called me personally and obviously it's
not a flattering story necessarily for
Oregon but I think he showed my point of
view I understand his but he has talked
about it publicly now can you give us
any thoughts on what you know any
insights on what he was saying or at
least reference anything you know I
would just say that you know he really
want to make the point that and I
understood it that they weren't actively
trying to hurt anybody and I didn't I
that wasn't in my reporting I'm either
that they could step off to the side and
she got help from athletic trainer if
they needed that you know they these
guys were pushing themselves to a point
at a certain point you know they want to
finish the workout I totally understood
that and I actually went back through
and added into my store rated you know
they could have stepped off the side if
they wanted to
um so I think that his his you know
biggest complaint which I'll just share
was this that you know they weren't
trying to outright and punish these guys
but that was him take away and I
understand that I just know that you
know however many you know 100-plus guys
they got through it just fine but three
did have to go to the hospital i think
that's newsworthy will they continue
these workouts you know a statement from
oregon last night from the athletic
department said that they've made
modifications to the program going
forward so they wouldn't have any kind
of similar incidents of a pretty mia
exact phrasing from the athletic
department statement but you know as an
acknowledgement that they kind of had
reviewed it look like what had happened
and we're going to try to you know maybe
make some are safeguards Andrew thanks
for joining us great work on the story
thank you I appreciate an Anthony Andrew
gray the orgo nian with the three
players hospitalized there this is a
whole different world now when it comes
to how much time you get with players
what you do with those players the
safety working out but three players
hospitalized that that's what was
surprising here and there was a label of
there there weren't intense workouts
last year there was the story the rumor
that they weren't as in good a shape as
you would expect with Oregon with the
style that they play that they would
have been in better shape did that play
into this not sure but three players
hospitalized the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]